I wanted to be documented the first time
I ever pull a card super insane so then
what was the most valuable piece of
advice you've ever received in your
career it's actually an extremely
raunchy piece of well a couple things my
dad gave me great advice which is your
word is your bond so I was a Salesman
and so that meant embellishing slash
lying was part of the equation in my
youth and I've become far less of that
which is amazing because that helps
especially in this transparent world so
thank God for that huge but I always
think about this there was a super
raunchy 80 year old liquor salesman when
I was fifteen that came up to me and
said something super inappropriate he's
and I don't remember what the context of
why he was saying it but the saying was
kid you don't know what you have until
you sleep with it
and it was kind of like the what he it
was a very Jersey 80 year old mobster
talk but what he was basically saying to
me is like look don't overthink this
until you go through it you won't know
you know there's a great Russian saying
that says man thinks and God laughs and
like that's how I think about stuff like
I could have a million plans and then
tomorrow a helicopter can go through the
building that we're in right like
yesterday New York like I just you know
that's the extreme but in the micro
business I could be like oh hey Jason's
gonna do this on this huge project in a
month and you know something might
happen Jason's family where he has to go
home for a month I [ __ ] it up you know
or like juice imma fall in love and like
has to move to Ohio like I don't like I
know I think about this stuff that like
as a true operator I think about this a
lot and it helps me be by the way I
think if anybody's listening right now
it speaks to why I'm not super anxious I
I know that I'm in control of nothing
which almost automatically by nature
makes me capable of controlling
everything
that's a big thing I'd like that one you
like that one it's super interesting to
me it's a huge it's a huge vulnerability
because you're not in control
[Music]
biggest news of my life there is nothing
besides buying the New York Jets that I
will do that is more exciting than what
I'm about to tell you several months ago
I got into negotiations with tops the
iconic sports card company and stops
Series two released today and in the
packs of tops series two first time I'm
ever gonna see it and the back and smoke
I mean Jesus Christ is a small print I'm
getting old but in the packs of top
Series 2 is an insert card called Gary
B's top entrepreneurs in baseball where
there is a 12 card set we pick 12 guys
and then there's so there's 12 cards
different players 12 different players
you get one of those in every 18 pack so
almost one or two in a box I think
that's going off the top my head and
then there's a dual Auto card where you
can get an autograph of me and the
player there's a in one of these packs
for example I could pull right now I
know it's more than 5,000 packs they do
a lot of writing to try to pull a card
of myself I wanted to be documented the
first time I ever pull a card of me in
it
there it is Jose Ramirez geremy's top I
cannot believe I just pulled it I'm so
awesome
how insane is this I am literally on a
[ __ ] baseball card are you [ __ ]
kidding me
this is insane that was so [ __ ] cool
that was so [ __ ] cool that was
awesome one of the latest ventures for
him is a curated set of cards inside at
ops nationwide release of cards he is
Gary Vaynerchuk how are you Gary Vee
well rich I'm okay but last night's KD
situation and my Knicks future has me a
little bit on tilt this morning what's
good what's the scoop are your tops
national release of cards that you've
got a curated set of cards inside I know
you were talking about trading cards
last time you were here I give you the
floor on what why are you so interested
in this well rich because I basically am
an entrepreneur because of baseball
cards and I'm 43 in that classic 87 88
89 those great known as the junk junk
waxy era the cards aren't worth anything
but it was the height of popularity of
sports cards sports cards are the thing
that I most associate myself and my
youth to and if you told 15 year-old me
that I would have a trading card
literally in packs of tops I would you
know it this is think this is easily the
single single coolest thing I'm ever
gonna do in my life outside of buying
the New York Jets so this is what top
entrepreneurs in baseball that's what
this Gary B's topical entrepreneurs in
baseball and one in every 18 packs
there's an insert Gary these top
entrepreneur in baseball Luciano and I
Lou on my team went through a lot of
data and you know it's a fun set because
for every Alex Bregman there's a Trevor
may because Trevor just happens to be a
phenomenal entrepreneur he you know may
not end up being the most valuable
baseball card because mineral relievers
don't really dictate the market but I we
really put a lot of effort into who's an
actual entrepreneur
and then so you have one and every 18
packs chance to get that insert and then
above and beyond that there's autographs
and special inserts one every five
thousand packs is the dual Auto rich you
can go to a store right now by a pack of
top series two baseball cards and
possibly pull out a Derek Jeter Gary Vee
dual Auto card so what is what is the
value of some of these cards that you're
pulling out of this pack if you just go
ahead and throw it in I guess some sort
of some sort of container yeah some sort
of coating or some sort of protective
covering Gary you're talking about the
grading system so I don't know yet they
just came out and so the value of these
cards is going to be figured out I'd
like to think that there'll be some
demand for my you know from
entrepreneurs that want my insert so
we'll see how that goes I mean the
market decides on that right and so
we'll see I mean there's a big national
convention in the last week of July in
Chicago I bought a table rich I'm
literally spending four days at the
National Convention as a dealer like
back in my teenage days so I'm excited
about hustling there and we will see
what the cards
[Music]
so if I'm going to be doing this I need
to be getting two moves the values of
followers not the tens of thousands yes
so I think that makes a lot of sense to
me so I think there's a lot of ways to
have that conversation I think I think
this is super important what you're
doing here I think the thing that I
always believe is to get to the millions
it's a cliche game of tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands millions that that
whole thing but if you're not anchored
in something that gives you enough
at-bats that is practical to the way
that you live your life
it's unachievable and what I mean by
that is putting yourself in a position
where you're recording at all times and
or starting a meaningful podcast
something that is the mother ship is an
imperative part to this model otherwise
it's not achievable I think the thing
that really runs through my mind is what
level of patience around
the vanity metric of followers is
running through your mind I think you
know the thing that I see you and I
speak to a lot of highly accomplished
people with you you answer perfectly
which is the same for everybody
regardless of where they want to deploy
that attention there's a there's a race
to a vanity number that I think is
hurting a lot of my contemporaries
people of your ilk in these genres that
I almost wish that LinkedIn and
Instagram and YouTube would eliminate
the follow count because I believe that
people that actually have something to
say would be more on their way of
achieving it but I think that human
behavior with those kind of diet reduces
the volume of Falls gives you both what
I'm saying is that people are so
influenced by the [ __ ] likes and
followers that they become a caricature
of that game not the behavior needed to
actually achieve what they're trying to
achieve I mean that is no question what
is transpired for me and my analyzing of
others and that are actually creating
meaningful impact
it's only through these channels has
been predicated on a commitment to
output of creative being talented enough
to have something to say and truly just
running the marathon with mera marathon
behavior versus sprint behavior zero
buying a fans zero caring about the
number making an outrageous commitment
to relat relat contextual creative at
scale which inherently a puts them in
position to have a viral moment which
could make what many want to happen very
quickly your you know someone like you
is always one piece of content d-roc and
I always talk we're always one piece of
content away from being at the next
level you know yeah we're you know it
and it is funny that there are a lot of
my friends who don't have this impact in
size that I have but I've had far more
viral singular moments you know I think
I'm winning by a death of a thousand
cuts MUC you know and so but we're in
play we always know tomorrow could be
the hundred million viewed YouTube video
we do know that and so I think you know
obviously this has me very excited
because I think first convincing someone
the value of recording everything or a
lot of things or the commit you know I
speak to a lot of super accomplished
people many of giving away fit the crowd
that gives away 50 to 99 percent of
their wealth the crowd I'm going to
speak to tomorrow at brilliant minds and
and it's very hard to get them motivated
to do a podcast three days a week in
perpetuity yet what they want is 55
million people to really pay attention
to them and and what's really ironic and
you'll definitely appreciate this
because nobody achieves something of
true without putting in the work like
they're also commonly the people that
understand how much work comes in play
to actually achieve something meaningful
which is how we actually got to this in
a world where many people are so busy
that are achieving meaningful things how
do I eliminate friction at scale to
allow them to be able to achieve the
creative output model that achieves the
goal at hand how we innovate show the
Westons things you'd like with a new
cultures would say opal to speak all of
this change we're gonna massive shift us
to being like another agency yes so I
think I think dictatorship you know my
willingness to fire Sarah Daniel and I I
mean it I mean it like it's it's a funny
answer it's a it's a it's a funny answer
but it's true like there's nothing a
couple things let's break it down into
ounces first and foremost do you know
how great it feels to not have a board
not be a hell not be a publicly-traded
that there's every single problem at
Vayner is 100% my fault there's nothing
I can't do I'm fully in charge it's the
truth like it's not fun to say that
because there's a fuckload of things
running through my head looking at faces
here of people who aren't happy right
the second so that doesn't feel great
but there's an incredible truth behind
that it's a very easy answer which is my
appetite to make a move predicated on
what I think is the right cadence to
articulate to the 50 most senior people
100 most senior people and their ability
to see that through as it evolves it's a
funny game though what Vayner stands for
is also interpreted very differently by
people there are people that have worked
at Vayner for seven years that are in
New York that think it's something very
different than what you think it is so I
think you also have to understand
ideology is formed in a very interesting
way right and so that is actually the
thing I least worry about on earth you
know in pockets that can deviate you
know when somebody is getting bullied by
their boss that's the least people first
thing on earth but that can happen in
pockets that can be happen in pockets
for four months it's very daunting when
you have passionate points of view and
real religious inside yourself yet the
company's at a scale of a thousand and
there's a million variables in play at
all times and you have to be thoughtful
this markets incredibly impossible
because of its laws of like how quickly
I can fire somebody who's a piece of
[ __ ]
you know like like there's a lot to the
right interpretive in a you have to be
very thoughtful I mean the 360 nature of
everything we're auditing now is so
remarkable because we live in a culture
where everybody's ready to sue about
everything at all times at all ways like
it's real fun like nothing's more fun
than being an employee you get to blame
somebody you know but when you're in it
and you're actually the last you know as
everyone here has probably felt if
you've gotten to the point where you
went from actually doing something to
the first time of managing something you
have a new perspective super easy and
fun to make fun of your parents until
you become a parent you realize
variables and so you know for me you
know I have to be empathetic and
balanced and all of that but keeping the
keeping the keeping the intent the you
know of being the best communications
infrastructure to support the objective
at hand that is contemporary to the
moment of what consumer behavior is
about as like in that narrow definition
of your question that's a piece of cake
I don't know anything else I will do an
all hands-on meeting in this company in
11 months and say we are only doing TV
if I believe for some reason TV cut
their prices by 90% and now that was the
best deal in communications I am NOT
romantic about a damn thing when it
comes to the execution of make having
smart thinking around great outputs
creatively in places where people
actually see them
[Music]
see friends to build friend Fang you
know we're seeing a lot like our pool in
traditional TV ads I think it's a huge
mistake and I think you're seeing it
because they're wasting money and they
don't care and I think that they the
biggest Delta is we we literally what's
amazing to watch these brands go so
heavy on traditional above-the-line
creative is that the great case study of
modern creative comes in the form of
Dollar Shave Club for whatever happened
at Dollar Shave Club after the fact the
Dollar Shave Club video is this
generations just do it or where's the
beef it really is an iconic piece of
creative that birthed the billion dollar
brand the number one mistake that direct
to consumer brands at scale are making
right now is not creating long-form
video on Facebook and YouTube to build
brand equity and that's how I see it and
I think there are couple brands that are
actually for that matter
purple mattress if you if you if you if
you nerd on this stuff you should go
look at what purple mattress is doing as
a company versus what Casper is doing as
a company right one is very hard core
DTC and is growing is the leader Casper
the purple is creating a lot of creative
ad-hoc some of it's not hitting but with
what I think they're committed to which
is something I'm more committed to which
is 180 thousand dollar production and
creative execution risk of making a
funny video a video that makes you cry a
video that makes you think if you hit
that your CAC and LTV numbers get really
good real fast because now you're
creating a brand and and that's the
ultimate goal
well I it means that the Facebook's of
the world the googles of the world are
getting more of their I mean it's crazy
you have two gals in middle of nowhere
starting a direct-to-consumer peanut
butter brand and two years later
spending more money on Facebook and
Instagram than Unilever does like if you
go talk to Facebook executives that run
their business
they are getting way bigger budgets from
companies you've never heard of than
from PepsiCo and Budweiser and all this
stuff and that is probably my favorite
thing that's kind of going on literally
literally when you look at the top
spenders on these platforms it will blow
your mind literally a brand you've never
heard of outspending coca-cola BMW and
that's because one trades on sales data
and another one trades on internal MMS
or reporting I don't I think it's very
difficult to give advice that says
become more talented be born with more
talent very not practical so where I
found myself was going to another place
that felt very practical to me and as
you can imagine it's all I ever saw for
the first 35 years of my life which was
work ethic was a controllable part of
the game that if you did that if you're
out working your competition practicing
after practice all the things we know
about sports and music and theater and
acting and other things that that was an
incredible advantage and in a time and
place where people were getting laid off
and things of that nature it hit the
right tone it was natural to me and the
timing was right to the more nuanced
question which I appreciate which means
you're paying attention over the last 18
to 24 months as the world changes as we
get into entitlement era after 15 years
of economic or ten years of great global
economic growth much like my concern
with entrepreneurship because there's so
much money in the system everybody's
idea gets funded and we're not building
businesses we're just building companies
to get more funding what has also
happened is a more human conversation
more Nordic and European centric than US
and China centric about work-life
balance about mental health issues about
burnout I found myself two years ago
watching contemporaries even friends
start to use me as a poster child of bad
that I was pushing too much burnout and
things of that nature
hustle porn and other things
and I was empathetic to it as much as I
was hurt and wanted to make 500 videos
of in the first book which is my Bible I
talked about if you want to work 9:00 to
5:00 and make 40,000 a year but you're
happy you've won I think I've been and I
have been incredibly consistent around
happiness not money and many other
things but to your point because of my
personality traits what was associated
was hustle and things that nature so I
have to take responsibility for that and
so over the last 24 months I have spent
more time and energy to contextualize
everything to make sure I'm covering the
basis so that people know where I stand
on this which is what I said earlier I
don't really regret it because I loved
business is my hobby but if one wants to
go to every softball game or every track
meet or you know work 31 hours a week
and they're fulfilled that makes me
happy I don't get the judge so yes I
think what's so great about
communication and so great about
advancements is you can create clarity
you can talk about different things I
talk a lot more about parenting today
than I did in the past because not even
because I'm a parent because I've been
more in tune to how I was parented so
yes I've definitely been more aggressive
in making sure the things that I've
always believed are more associated with
me because I have no interest in other
people painting a picture about me that
isn't true
[Music]
the one question well what is the one
piece of feedback you're most curious
the truth yeah but about what whatever
the hell is in front of them running an
operation is not a education or
philosophical exercise what do I want I
want to know exactly what is an issue
operationally right this second to you
from your perspective and you running
your world and how can I help the
reverse of that coin what can I do to
put you in the best position to succeed
are you looking to talk to me more often
are you talking to me less do you need
fight you need some leeway with your
financial P&L do you need me to rah-rah
the troops do you want me to go talk to
the most senior client because the
client that you work with which is the
second most senior client is giving you
a very difficult time I am in the
ambulance firefighting emergency doctor
bat phone business I am only built to
act in helping for you to succeed within
this framework and I believe when you
look at our organization the people that
have been with me for seven eight years
the people that are winning the most
really see it and the people that don't
hear it and think it's a thinking they
deploy cynicism that I'm just want to
hear myself speak and it's an ideology
and that I won't actually do it because
what's amazing about employees is how
many in this by the way I'm gonna set
this up on the podcast I'm actually very
excited to say this I actually think for
all the very thoughtful conversation we
just had I can feel it in my body right
now this piece of content may be the
piece that brings the most value I am
blown away by how many employees have
made judgments on their organizations
without trying to address it the amount
of my employees that come into my office
on year three call my bluff final
to address something I address it in 48
hours within a month whatever the issue
is they come back and say I can't
believe he did it
and then give me 31 other things that
happened in the first 36 months of their
tenure but they decided to be cynical
they vet with their friends at a beer
they talk about it in the girls bathroom
they tell their mother but they never
told me or the organization it is the
great shortcoming of employees in our
world today my friends call the
company's bluff call the bluff I mean if
you haven't gone to HR or to the CEO or
however your world is structured well
then you have no legs to stand on that
the company stinks if you have and they
haven't delivered vent away but until
you call the bluff then you're just
complaining because you like to complain
[Music]
before you go yes one is a photo yep and
the other thing oh also I forgot some oh
my god and a Jets thing you're amazing I
couldn't make you feel at home you're so
smooth that is
seriously how do you spell your name
[Music]